well I think what it does is it gives a
good portrait of the way ordinary people
feel about the big issues of the day and
these to the extent that that's
important in to the extent that that's
crucial to to policymaking and to public
understanding of this society I think
that's the contribution that it makes
well I certainly want to make sure that
the Pew Research Center continues to do
what it does when I'm no longer doing
running the pew research center I think
I've achieved a lot of what I set out to
achieve and I don't know if I have a
specific goal I certainly want to
continue to try to understand better how
the image of the United States is going
to evolve over time when we have a new
administration when they're new
challenges I think that's an important
task for me to continue in the future